des amas de branches mortes une terre
retournée rappelle qu'il existait une
forêt à cet emplacement dans cette zone
rasé en plein coeur du morvan
j'ai rencontré deux farouches défenseurs
de la forêt 500 habitants manifestent
pour stopper l'abattage de parcelles
entières
vous allez faut répartir et on sait
qu'elles reviendront pas feu 200 ans
pour refaire un une forêt et et en plus
on sait pas ce qu'il va se passer ni
mokuba donc est ce qu elle pourra se
refaire le fond du problème c'est que on
est quelques-uns penser que la forêt
devrait bien être est un bien commun
quoi comme comme l'air et l'eau
finalement donc peut-être essayer de
légiférer sur scherrer comment faire
pour travailler correctement faut
respecter la vie
ces habitants redoutent de voir
disparaître cette forêt au centre de la
bourgogne le massif du morvan
[Musique]
une forêt aux multiples essences des
chaînes d être des merisiers
ces espèces mélange et d'âge différents
sont régulièrement rasé au profit
d'intérêts privés
85 % de la forêt du morvan appartient à
des particuliers
ce jour là j'accompagne trois militants
sur une parcelle où les arbres ont été
rasés
pour sylvain angerand ingénieur
forestier
ces dégâts sont une menace pour la
biodiversité des sols
en fait là on est sans doute dans le lit
du cours d'eau et ils sont passés avec
les engins ici on va très bien il ya une
trace de vous la le traces de roues là
ils sont passés tellement qu'ils ont
tous des caps est le seul normalement il
a fleuri ici on voit bien on a encore la
couche d'humus on la voit là la terre un
peu de noix et tout en bande à la roche
et on va la roche mais ont été creusés
tellement profondément et presque 80 cm
que du coup la rochelle en bas là on a
détruit un sol qui s'était constitué sur
sur des centaines d'années quand on
quand on voit ça et c'est il va falloir
énormément de temps pour le reconstituer
si on y arrive parce qu'à un moment très
très difficile que la forêt reviennent
dans le morvan
après ce que l'on appelle une coupe rase
les forêts de feuillus sont le plus
souvent remplacés par des résineux comme
l'épicéa ou le douglas originaire
d'amérique du nord
là ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que ils ont
planté par tous d'une glace ouais on a
dû nous glace douglas voilà tout et
aligne son espace et de m encore un
douglas douglas est en fait que tout
d'avoir une forêt comme un côté qui soit
diversifiée avec du chêne dû être et des
arbres qui sont de différentes tailles
différents étages qui sont pas plantés
en rang d'oignons voilà tout est alignée
et on va se retrouver avec non pas une
forêt c'est pas une forêt c'est une
plantation on est passé à une logique
agricole
[Musique]
des arbres plantés en ligne comme des
champs de maïs
l'épicéa et le douglas ont transformé le
paysage la forêt du morvan est désormais
peuplées à 50% de résineux
ces arbres atteignent l'âge adulte trois
fois plus vite que les feuillus et
répondent ainsi à une logique économique
comme dans l'agriculture intensive
[Musique]
la forêt rapporte en moyenne 1 à 2% par
an c'est un placement sûr
vingt mille propriétaires se partagent
le massif du morvan
parmi eux des institutionnels
la caisse des dépôts des banques
la caisse d'epargne des assurances comme
axa ou encore la caisse nationale de
prévoyance à rolle de blanot est l'un
des rares propriétaires à avoir accepté
d'être filmé cet enfant de la région
vient de planter des pins douglas à la
place des feux d'origine
c'est plus lucratif
voilà ça c'est des jeux typiques des
peuplements feuillus de médiocre qualité
c'est à voilà quand il était debout
vous aviez 3,3 perche qui devait même
pas faire un devis stères de bois de
chauffage
ça veut dire une valeur marchande la
valeur de ce pied là c'était un euro et
demi 2 euros ce qui est médiocre alors
que les douglas ceux qui sont là pour le
même âge complète valoir 50 euros ces
arbres aligner divise
pour les défenseurs de la nature on ne
peut plus parler de forêts naturelles
[Musique]
non ce pour une forêt naturelle non mais
je n'en pas le problème au bout de
quelques années on ne reverra plus
l'alignement des arbres ça fera de
belles chutait de douglas ou de résineux
dans les vosges dans les alpes ça fait
bonheur des touristes
je vois pourquoi ça ne pourront pas le
faire ici quoi malgré la jeunesse de ces
arbres la forêt montre déjà des signes
de faiblesse et compte des centaines
d'arbres morts le grand ennemi des
arbres aujourd'hui c'est le
réchauffement climatique depuis trois
ans en france la moitié des plantations
d'épicéas ont été décimés par la
sécheresse est un insecte le scolyte
dans l'est de la france où l'épidémie à
démarré des agents de l'onef l'organisme
public en charge de la gestion des
forêts constate les dégâts
oh là là c'est flagrant
voilà les insectes qui sont drôles ils
sont en train de forer le pied de larmes
il est recouvert de sciure voilà quand
on voit ça l'espérance de vie et 2 allée
de moi tout cas c'est celui-là problème
réglé
elle a su il a été piqué au printemps
puis au printemps cela qu'il a réagi il
a fait des coulées de scène on voit
qu'il a cherché à se défendre
donc là on voit des piqûres en fait qui
font la taille d'une tête d'épinglé un
petit peu partout sur l'arbre est en
fait ils passent à travers les corses et
après il vient pondre entre l'écorcé le
bois est une espèce de pulpe très
nutritive en fait pour l'insecte et du
coup les larves vont se développer en
mangeant tout cette pulpe là sauf qu'en
fait la sève circule dans cette pulpe
donc en fait en quelques semaines il n'y
a plus aucune cf qui circulent dans
l'arbre c'est à dire que lola ont les
mêmes plus connecté avec le bas et c'est
pour ça qu'il va mourir très rapidement
[Musique]
philippe canal représentant syndical à
l'eau nf dénonce les conséquences de la
monoculture dans le morvan
vous avez en général qu'une seule
essence
donc vous n'avez qu'une seule réponse
aux problèmes climatiques alors que
quand vous avez des peuplements avec un
mélange d'essence de chêne de hêtre de
charme
eh bien vous avez plusieurs réponses une
espèce moeurs certains individus
d'autres peuvent survivre mais quand
vous avez une seule essence du même âge
sur des grandes surfaces et que vous
avez une attaque d'insectes comme ce
qu'il ya sur les pistes et à des
attaques de scolytes est bien là donc ou
sur des dizaines des centaines
d'hectares
tu t'es mort
face au risque lié aux coupes rases et à
la monoculture que fait l'état au mois
de juin dernier à la maison du parc
régional du morvan des associations
opposées à l'industrialisation de la
forêt organise un débat
ils veulent interpeller les pouvoirs
publics
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
donc à saint-brisson la maison du parc
du parc naturel régional du morvan qui
cette année fête ses 50 ans le président
du parc prend la parole devant des
habitants très remonté contre les
pratiques industrielles comme lucienne
militante de la première heure là
maintenant les coupes ans ils vont avoir
une réglementation très clair parce que
ça continue et rien ne change et ça m'a
plu quoi voir dans une forêt ça y est
nous tous le monde à part quelques
forestier pour qui c'est dans la logique
de la gestion choisir c'est normal mais
voilà je pense pas que ce soit
majoritaire dans l'opinion et voilà on
souhaite que ça bouge
depuis deux ans soutenue par une
majorité d'élus de la région
le président du parc tentent de faire
pression sur l'état pour mieux encadrer
les pratiques des exploitants en 2019
sylvain mathieu inscrit dans la charte
du parc du morvan des objectifs comme
promouvoir une sylviculture sans coupes
rases et proche de la nature
ce qu'on demandait c'est que l'état
puisse refuser une coupe rase dès lors
que l'impact environnemental est jugé
trop trop fort ça peut être un impact
sur les paysages un impact sur les sols
un impact sur la biodiversité ou un
impact sur la ressource en eau or l'état
nous a répondu leur premièrement donc
vous n'avez pas écrire ça dans la charte
on ne pourra pas refuser pour un motif
environnementale parce que ça n'est
prévu par aucun texte
enfin voilà dans la discussion avec
l'état
j'ai réuni nous fermer toutes les portes
c'était non à toutes nos demandes et
pour nous c'était inacceptable dans un
premier temps le président du parc et
les élus refusent de piller en ce bras
de fer
nous n'étions pas très enclins à
réécrire notre charte
moi j'estime et qu'on avait la
légitimité démocratique document voté à
l'unanimité des élus du territoire ça
veut dire quelque chose
sauf qu'à un moment donné l'état nous a
dit mais si vous maintenez cette
formulation vous prenez le risque que
nous et à qu'on ne vous renouvelle pas
votre label votre classement ce qui
signifie ce qui signifie donc on serait
on aurait pu le label parc on pourrait
plus se prévaloir d'être à un parc donc
à menacer tech le temps qu'on me plierai
pas il ne verseraient pas la subvention
annuelle de 100 à 1000 euros
à la préfecture de dijon j'aurais bien
aimé rencontrer le préfet qui est accusé
d'avoir menacé de couper les subventions
mais il a été nommé ailleurs son
successeur ne connaîtraient pas encore
bien le dossier
c'est donc le secrétaire général qui est
chargé de répondre à mes questions
est ce que l'état a menacé le parc de ne
pas renouveler son label alors il n'est
pas dans les habitudes de l'état de
menacer quiconque mais non puisque la
charte devait être conforme un certain
nombre de critères il ne l'était pas
parce qu'on ne peut pas inscrire dans
une charte de parc des dispositions
réglementaires qui obligerait les
propriétaires forestiers a demandé à
soumettre leurs projets de coupes un
avis du parc ce n'est pas envisageable
c'est pas possible réglementairement
donc l'état ne pouvait pas autoriser le
parc a adopté cette charte en en a
discuté ensemble le parquet fini par
retirer ces dispositions qui empêchait
l'adoption de la charte et pas trop le
choix sinon l'état lui enlever les
120000 euros de subventions c'était un
choix du parc entre la protection de
l'environnement et les intérêts
économiques
l'état a choisi sa priorité le bois
d'une manière générale c'est une
économie qui fait vivre le moment il ya
cinq ou six mille emplois qui dépendent
du bois dans le morvan
donc c'est important et donc il faut
pouvoir assurer la pérennité de ces
emplois et donc il s'agit pas de
réglementer de manière autoritaire pour
dire vous ferez q si vous ferez plus à
merci monsieur perrin mais dans rien je
n'irais pas jusqu'à dire que c'était un
plaisir mais là
en france les propriétaires privés
possèdent les trois quarts de la forêt
ils sont trois millions et demi pour la
plupart c'est le fruit d'un héritage
dans la sarthe la famille d'amécourt se
transmet le château et la forêt de
génération en génération
antoine d'amécourt possède aujourd'hui
750 hectares de forêt
personnage clé du monde forestier je
l'avais rencontré tout au début de mon
enquête
antoine d'amécourt et président de
france il va la fédération des
propriétaires privés avec ses 41 mille
adhérents
il est à la tête du plus gros syndicat
du secteur c'est un lobbyiste très actif
il faut être réaliste ce constat dire
que le sujet toute la journée il va
participer à des rencontres avec des
parlementaires et des représentants de
la filière bois à l'ordre du jour le
réchauffement climatique et ses
conséquences sur la forêt le social
c'est important l'environnemental c'est
super important
lui non pêche que la faurecia pas
l'économie ces morts en fera ni
l'environnement ni sociale ni sociétal c
ben oui puisque
l'argent qu'on remet pas du ciel si on
veut gérer une forêt si on veut qu'ils
aient de la biodiversité si on veut
qu'ils aient tout ça il faut que cette
filière la partie économique on la
laisse pas tomber
c'est à mon avis très important devant
les sénateurs
antoine d'amécourt représente les
intérêts des propriétaires de forêts le
président de france il va prend la
parole pour défendre les coupes rases
qui font polémique
la société il faut lui expliquer
pourquoi on fait des coupes rases et ça
c'est de la communication donc ne
partons pas du principe que la coupe
rase la société l'acceptera pas
expliquons ici antoine d'amécourt ne
manque pas de soutiens
plusieurs sénateurs sont propriétaires
de forêts comme le président du sénat
gérard larcher
je marchais c'est un homme de terrain
vide le sénat mais il est originaire de
formation il est propriétaire forestier
dont il est adhérent france il va et
c'est bien donc il y connaît le sujet de
la forêt puisqu'il est lui même
propriétaire forestier
tous les métiers ont pour les métiers si
vous parlez de locuteurs qui connaissent
pas le sujet antoine d'amécourt avait
accepté de nous laisser filmer ses
forêts et de répondre à toutes nos
questions
mais le président de france il va à
changer d'avis il n'a plus jamais
répondu à mes nombreuses sollicitations
à la lecture de ce document on comprend
mieux pourquoi il se méfie des
journalistes en témoignent ses
recommandations aux membres de son
syndicat
nous vous incitons à la plus grande
prudence si vous êtes contacté par un
journaliste il suggère également des
éléments de langage
par exemple si on vous dit
la coupe rase est à bannir répondait non
c'est un mode de sylviculture parmi
d'autres le syndicat propose à ses
adhérents d'éviter l'emploi trop
fréquent de cette expression coupe rase
et de privilégier les termes de coupes
de renouvellement ou de récolte
cette rhétorique ne convaincra pas les
militants écologistes du morvan ils se
sont donné rendez vous à paris devant
les bureaux de france il va à deux pas
des champs elysées
ils sont venus interpeller antoine
d'amécourt le président de france il va
sur les dégâts des coupes rases
bonjour une petite livraison
c'est une carte postale pour me suis
donné cours voilà on est l'association
canopée collectif sos forêt les
habitants du bien et on vient vous
remettre une petite carte postale
ouais bon bah on va tendre donc est-ce
que vous accepté une invitation dans le
morceau
nous allons faire mal aux pieds avant le
fermage et pied bon jeu l'association
canopée
c'est un peu compliqué vous comprendre
des matra d'ariane portes fermées comme
ça alors si vous pouvez rentrer ou
simplement prendre rendez vous on vois
pas ce que vient ouais on est là pour ça
on vous invite à venir dans le morvan au
mois de septembre visite est avec nous
les coupes rases votre réponse et le
silence ça en dit long
voilà vous dire voir bientôt bientôt oui
j'ai le pied coincé quand même faudrait
un petit peu la portée très chaud sortir
voilà méchante une bonne journée à très
bientôt
au revoir à l'est à ce jour le syndicat
des propriétaires privés n'a pas accepté
l'invitation des militants dans le
morvan
[Musique]
à l'ombre des forêts se livrent des
batailles environnementale mais
économique aussi l'arbre qui attire
toutes les convoitises peut atteindre
l'âge de cinq cents ans il peut avoir
une très grande valeur lorsqu'il est
très ancien le chêne
[Musique]
tristan sus m'a donné rendez vous dans
une chênaie en bourgogne
il conseille des investisseurs dans la
gestion de leurs forêts il est un grand
connaisseur des vieux chênes et de leur
valeur marchande dans un chenil à
différents produits low petit nombre en
valeur dans un chêne on appelle ça la
bille de pied c'est les 400 premiers
mètres c'est de l'ébénisterie
c'est la production de meyrin pour faire
des tonneaux et ça c'est des bois qui
valent 400 500 600 euros du mètre cube
après vous avez de la charpente donc le
prix là et est inférieur et ensuite vous
avez des traverses traverses de chemin
de fer par exemple donc là le prix
encore plus faible et après vous avez
toutes les branches qui reste la seule
bois de chauffage alors comme ça il faut
au moins cinq mètres cubes 5 mètres
cubes à 200 euros il vomit long si vous
avez 50 arbres comme ça à l'hectare 50
ans vingt mille euros le fait cinquante
mille euros
dans la région de chalon-sur-saône se
trouve l'un des plus importants sites de
transformation de chaînes en france
lusine fabrique des traverses de chemin
de fer et du parc est vendu dans le
monde entier
david chavaux est à la tête de
l'entreprise ces affaires marchent bien
mais beaucoup d'autres scieries
françaises sont menacées elles n'ont
plus les moyens d'acheter du bois brut
[Musique]
cette matière première est devenu trop
cher depuis l'arrivée sur le marché de
nouveaux clients
depuis 2010 c'est la chine qui vient
acheter en france et avec une demande et
un besoin qui est sans commune mesure
avec ce qui se passait jusqu'à lors et
ce besoin a créé un véritable
déséquilibre dans notre filière puisque
c'est plus de 25% de la récolte de
chaînes du territoire français qui est
finalement parti en asie dans ces
dernières années et ça a créé un manque
important dans les scieries françaises
le prix du chêne brut a été multiplié
par deux difficile pour les français de
s'aligner
[Musique]
et
pour comprendre l'appétit des chinois il
faut remonter quelques années en arrière
après avoir coupé la plupart de leurs
forêts entre les années 50 et 70
aujourd'hui ils plantent la population
l'armée et même le président se
mobilisent pour verdir le pays pendant
que leurs arbres poussent les chinois
vont chercher du bois ailleurs
[Musique]
ces dernières années en france les
exportations de bois vers la chine se
sont accélérées elles ont été
multipliées par 5 en douze ans dans la
région ile-de-france tout près de la
commune de corbeil essonnes un énorme
vacarme perturbent la tranquillité des
promeneurs des chaînes sont chargés dans
des normes containers à la manoeuvre
jérôme vacants d'art exploitants
forestiers il a acheté 416 tome de
troncs d'arbres des grumes de quoi
remplir c'est ce container il revend
cette matière première en europe et en
asie
[Applaudissements]
à ses côtés sa cliente elle souhaite
rester anonyme
elle surveille de près le chargement qui
rejoindra le port du havre puis celui de
shanghai jérôme vacants d'art affirment
qu'ils en voient surtout vers l'asie des
bois de second choix
l'atout de la chine c'est de pouvoir
envoyer tous les bois les bois tordu les
mauvais bois et ont ils leur faut aussi
un peu de belles qualités et c'est sûr
parce qu'on ne peut pas envoyer que des
mots je vois ça c'est une certitude
un mélange un mélange n'y a pas de très
beaux bois toutes les villes de piété
les bois ils sont conservés ici les
chinois achètent re est il donc du bois
peu prisé en france ce n'est pas
l'impression que va nous donner
l'acheteuse
à des enjeux
on n'est pas
ce schème ne fera pas le voyage d'autres
de meilleure qualité partiront pour la
chine
[Applaudissements]
à chalon sur saône nous retournons voir
le patron de la scierie
je lui montre des photos prises lors du
chargement des containers que pense-t-il
de la qualité de ses chaînes ça c'est
des bois qui sont parfaits pour elle et
pour fabriquer de la traverse par
exemple je les achète tout de suite
c'est voilà je vous montre les mêmes sur
la plateforme
je vous en montre qu'ils sont moins bien
de ça chez moi c'est précisément le type
de bois qu'on est capable de transformer
pour fabriquer du parquet dans les
qualités les plus belles que de ce que
je vois là c'est difficile de juger sur
photo c'est précisément le bois que vous
trouvez sur mon parc à grumes il n'y a
pas de différence
david chavaux voudrait que les chaînes
brut ne soient plus vendus en dehors de
l'union européenne ce n'est pas du tout
l'avis des propriétaires privés
[Musique]
en indre et loire dans la forêt
d'amboise
gilles de boncourt est à la tête de la
plus grande coopérative de chaînes en
europe
[Musique]
ce sont des chaînes qui viennent de
différents crus de la touraine amboise
avec ses collaborateurs il inspecte les
bois coupé récemment on fait en sorte
pour défaut soit au dessus pour être
visible gilles de boncourt se réjouit de
la montée du cours du chêne heureusement
en quatre ans le prix du chêne à plus ou
moins doubler et ça a permis de redonner
de la rentabilité à ses forêts de chênes
qui nous n'avez plus ça nous permet de
réinvestir parce que sinon on arrivait à
un moment donné où les investissements
coûter plus cher que leurs revenus ce
qui est très important c'est que les
belles qualités restent bien en europe
restent bien en france en particulier
donc on a tout intérêt à vendre
localement à chaque fois qu'on le peut
mais parfois on ne peut pas comme gilles
de boncourt les propriétaires privés
veulent continuer à vendre leur bois au
plus offrant sans contrainte au sénat
anne catherine loisier et présidente de
la commission en charge des forêts
elle est elle-même gestionnaires et
copropriétaires de forêt elle reconnaît
qu'il est difficile de freiner le
commerce lucratif des chaînes avec la
chine
si le propriétaire champions qui va être
mieux payés quand ils vont en chine que
quand ils vont il va avoir un calcul
économique et à ce jour les dispositions
légales existantes
on peut pas l'empêcher et comme les prix
n'ont cessé de grimper en 2015 pour
limiter les exportations de bois brut
vers la chine
l'état a eu une idée
[Musique]
pour les chênes de la forêt publique il
a créé un label un arbre labellisé doit
être transformé obligatoirement une
première fois sur le sol européen
ce n'est qu'ensuite qu'il peut être
exporté
à lons le saunier dans le jura
une vente de chaînes est organisée par
l'office national des forêts david chat
vous est venu repérer des lots de bois
qu'il voudrait acheter aux enchères
l'après midi combien 60 ou 65 m2 à 2 m 2
il s'agit de chêne labellisé b6 ils ne
peuvent donc pas être vendus brut en
dehors de l'europe
la plupart des lots de bois en forêt
publique sont réservés à la vente à des
transformateurs nationaux en revanche
pour la forêt privée on a à ce jour
aucun outil de protection de phase aller
à l'exportation de grumes vers les pays
étrangers et principalement le bassin
asiatiques
[Musique]
la vente aux enchères va commencer da
avoue espère acquérir les chaînes
qu'il a estimé le matin même
chaque année une centaine de ventes de
ce type sont organisées par le nfc est
une des missions de cet organisme qui
gère la forêt publique française ainsi
notre présence nous allons commencer
parmi les acheteurs des représentants de
syrie des exploitants des fabricants de
tonneaux ils sont une cinquantaine à se
disputer les 128 l'eau c'est le plus
offrant qui l'emportent pour le prochain
lot david chavaux propose douze mille 50
euros le daily mail au match d'un très
beau lot de bois-rouge absolument des
contrats donnés dans le cours de la 30e
on est pas toujours connu évidemment
c'est le principe en est on est très
contents du tout pour dominer le le chef
d'entreprise vient d'acheter
suffisamment de bois pour faire tourner
sa scierie pendant deux semaines depuis
la création du label de l'eau nf
il n'a plus de concurrent asiatique pour
les ventes de la forêt publique
officiellement
au cours de mon enquête je découvre que
certains contours de la loi quelque part
en france paul dirige une petite scierie
ils ne respectent pas les contraintes
imposées par le label de l'office
national des forêts au lieu de
transformer le chêne de la forêt
publique en europe il le vend
directement à des acheteurs chinois
je trouve dans mon réseau des hommes de
haye je sais pas comment on appelle ça
qu'ils vont accepter de de créer une
société dans laquelle je n'apparais pas
et voilà et ensuite par mes yeux de
détritus lourde entre plusieurs
fournisseurs on arrive à aidé à
dissimuler la matière qui était acheté
des à l'os et repartiront sans problème
sur le dit grâce à cette combine
paul envoie 70% de ses achats en asie je
n'utilise pas ces pratiques je vais
faire un résultat comptable de l'ordre
de 30 mille euros annuels
je facilement 150000 euros dont il
bénéficie sur la société
à ce jour cole n'a jamais été pris la
main dans le sac
[Musique]
l'eau nf a connaissance de ces fraudes
mais n'a aucun pouvoir de contrôle à cet
agent a été témoin de nombreux trafics
on constate nous sur le terrain
concrètement qui a des bois labellisé
qui peuvent partir on va voir les
camions arrivés sur le dépôt et d'autres
camions de repartir sous la forme d'un
container non on va le voir qui peuvent
partir en asie par exemple est ce que
les choses à politiques sont alertés de
problèmes là est le problème il est
remonté et clairement il n'y a pas de
volonté politique d'aller à l'encontre
parce que ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait se mettre à l'encontre de la
sphère industrielle il n'y a pas de
volonté politique death metal en compte
de cette serre aujourd'hui
voilà plusieurs semaines que je cherche
à interviewer le ministre de
l'agriculture en charge de la forêt sans
réponse de son service de communication
je vais donc à sa rencontre
[Musique]
ce soir là julien de normandie
participent à un débat public 1 il
connaît bien le sujet il a travaillé sur
la labellisation des chênes de la forêt
publique certaines industries labellisés
par un jeu d'écritures on me voit du
bois en asie labellisés qui provient de
la forêt publique c'est quelque chose
que j'ai découvert au fil de mon oncle
est est ce que vous êtes au courant
en fait le dossier nommé parenté
est-ce que vous s'était renforcé les
contrôles justement pour
qualification est atterré
jean-thierry dépensés pour l'information
ne serait donc pas remonter jusqu'aux
ministres quant à élargir le label à la
forêt privée
il ne ferme pas la porte ils
représentent que par important mais pas
la totalité de
dumas site festif conseil oui moi mon
mobilité c'est d'aller plus loin sur le
sujet de manière très claire
[Musique]
à en croire le ministre l'avenir des
propriétaires privés pourrait connaître
quelques changements
[Musique]
un tiers de la forêt française se trouve
à 7000 kilomètres des frontières de
l'hexagone
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique en
amérique du sud
le département de la guyane il est
recouvert à 96 % de forêts la masoni
française s'étend sur 8 millions
d'hectares
c'est la plus grande de l'union
européenne en août 2019 alors que la
forêt brésilienne est en feu
emmanuel macron veut faire de la guyane
un exemple amazonie c'est notre bien
commun nous sommes tous concernés
la france est sans doute encore plus que
d'autres puisque nous sommes amazonien
la guyane est en amazonie elle est un
trésor pour notre climat
grâce à l'oxygène qu'elle aimait et
grâce au carbone qu'elle capture
au delà des discours comment l'état
prend il soin de l'amazone i française
en guyane pour avoir un bon point de vue
sur la forêt il faut prendre de la
hauteur
doma saunier travail au milieu des
arbres depuis plus de vingt ans il est
guide touristique
[Musique]
[Rires]
à 40 km à vol d'oiseau de cayenne je
découvre les premiers dégâts causés par
l'exploration minière
la forêt est grignotée par endroits des
milliers d'hectares sont mises à nu pour
libérer lors de ces sols
[Musique]
un peu plus loin des installations
minières encore en activité ont créé
d'énormes trous béants
cette déforestation n'a rien d'illégal
elle est autorisée par l'état
propriétaire de l'amazonie française
[Musique]
la plupart des sites miniers se situe au
nord de la guyane
en 1990 3 126 hectares de forêts sont
détruits par les mines d'or
trente ans plus tard ce sont 27 mille
hectares presque 100 fois plus
chaque année de nouvelles demandes
d'exploitation font planer le risque
d'une déforestation bien plus importante
tout a commencé avec des pme familiale
une d'entre elles se situent dans la
région de saül en plein coeur de la
forêt amazonienne pierre rey exploite
cette mine d'or depuis 20 ans cette
figure locale est l'un des rares
exploitants a accepté de m'ouvrir ses
portes
raffi ma fille aînée
ok à plus de gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
impossible de visiter la mine à pied je
découvre le site à bord de son quad
sa concession s'étend sur 100 kilomètres
carrés
ici pour extraire l'or le procédé est
simple la terre est arrachée du sol elle
est concassé puis passer sous une eau
sous pression
le métal jaune est recueilli par
décantation
le reste est ensuite rejetée dans ces
bassins pour exploiter l'or la forêt
rasé kilomètre par kilomètre
mais pour le propriétaire de la mine on
ne peut pas parler de déforestation
madame pour moi ça c'est pas des
forestiers a cédé sa ccc sas est
nettoyée pour moi parce que j'ai des
hommes qui travaillent
il faut que les alentours du de là où on
travaille soit un minimum propres de
façon à ce que les gens puissent pas se
mettre en embuscade pour pour pour
porter préjudice
c'est pas que pour protéger ses pur et
quand vous êtes un endroit madame nous
on nettoie autour de chez nous c'est
comme ça c'est traditionnel
en guyane l'état oblige les miniers à
reboiser après exploitation mais
seulement à hauteur de 25 à 30% de la
superficie de la forêt détruite mais
cette obligation peu contraignantes
n'est pas toujours respectée à une demi
heure de vol de cayenne
thomas saunier le militant nous emmène
sur un site fermé il y as presque un an
[Musique]
sur place nous découvrons des centaines
d'arbres couchés à terre sur une
superficie d'un kilomètre carré
d'un bel arbre tant que l'était
debout sans l'ombre des arbres la
chaleur est étouffante
tout ça sur des arbres adultes c'est des
sables qui avait plusieurs siècles c'est
sûr donc là on a coupé des mastodondes
la forêt ça fait un petit peu en
exposition macabre de la forêt quoi
savoir pousser mais savoir pas pousser
comme avant tu reviens dans 50 ans il y
aura sûrement faut espérer qu'il y aura
peut-être un couvert végétal mais on
verra
clairement la différence entre ce type
de forêt est ce qu'il ya ici ici c'est
possible qu'ils aient une espèce de
cambrousse d'une végétation très basses
très dense des herbes des machins mais
la biodiversité les perdu l'un ici elle
est perdue clairement l'activité minière
n'a pas seulement détruit la forêt elle
a laissé derrière elle d'autres traces
de son passage
quand je vois des morceaux de plastique
qui traînent des morceaux de bâches à
moitié éventrée
là on a des gaines en plastique mais ça
c'est choquant enfin je veux dire on
peut pas accepter que en pleine forêt
primaire avant leur passage que ça ça
reste les sas
tout ça c'est de la bâche
désolé c'est pas acceptable on a des
bottes des bottes avec une petite
production de moustiques un petit peu de
palu un petit peu dingue si vous voulez
ça va avec la mine là on a dit plastique
plastic des huiles la forêt primaire
vous remercier ça doit pas être ça le
modèle le modèle sais pas mais tu as km
de forêt primaire par terre pour générer
un million huit de chiffre d'affaires
c'est les chiffres de l'artisan mis un
million huit est-ce que ça ça coûte ça
vaut un million huit
profitant de notre présence le défenseur
de la forêt a organisé la visite d'une
personnalité locale
voilà la machine gibert
pas tous les jours
maire de kourou s'était fortement
opposée à l'implantation de la mine qui
suit le dossier
le maire françois ringuet découvre le
site pour la première fois donc on
allant voir la soeur lassé du stockage
de terre sûrement voilà là c'est de la
terre végétale
donc ils ont récupéré de la terre
végétale pour mon découvrent ensemble
là il ya tout un tas de petits sacs
chargés de sa terre végétale et il
prépare il peut par des jeunes plants
ces plants auraient dû servir à la
revégétalisation du site
il semble avoir été abandonnée
ce qui est le plus dur c'est de voir que
je prends des exemples comme la côte et
là ils ont commencé le bout il aurait pu
tout simplement autorités les arbres qui
sont là c'était mon simple ils ont l'ont
pas fait pourquoi je pense qu'à un
moment donné il ya certainement des
contrôles par les services de l'état
donc tu montres lors la pépinière et peu
après par la suite quand les services y
partent il laisse tomber
c'est dommage la société minière prétend
avoir déjà fait 80% du travail de
revégétalisation et promet de revenir
pour finir ses plantations
mais ce n'est pas le seul problème
l'exploitation a attiré des garimpeiros
des chercheurs d'or illégaux au consul
est chargée ou polo souvent installés
près des mines
il profite du filon le maire a demandé
un survol en drones autour du site pour
les repérer à deux kilomètres à peine
voici ce qu'il découvre
[Musique]
c'est de la faute des arbres abattus des
cours d'eau pollués témoigne de la
présence de plusieurs campements
illégaux
[Musique]
on a vu deux camps qui sont vides wen a
pas d'activité mais on a vu que l'on
était assez je pense qu'il ya quand même
des activités un policier témoin bas
salaires à ses frais à partir du moment
que les gens sont au courant que le
filon d'or il était ici peut-être que
pour une personne pour une entreprise
les plus d'intérêt dressé puisqu'ils ont
fait du chiffre bien peut-être que les
autorisations sont terminées mais pour
un orpailleur clandestins à partir du
monde tu sais que le site c'est ici tu
restes là n'iront pas ailleurs les
clandestins ne se cache même pas thomas
saunier en reperd 1 à la lisière de la
forêt non la glace non plus je viens du
brésil où est ce que tu veux il
travaille sur un campement de
clandestins à proximité tu travailles ah
bah ouais à trois heures trois heures
non là on a vu mis à dos et non j'ai pas
peur pourquoi j'aurais peur de la police
pourquoi je mens furet on n'est pas des
assassins on risque rien en fait ils
risquent rien quoi
au pire de se faire saisir le matériel
qui sont même pas reconduits à la
frontière parce que ce serait trop
coûteux de faire venir des idées qu à
rapatrier tout le monde sait qu'ils sont
là ok thomas h
les mines d'or illégale sont
responsables de la moitié de la
déforestation
plus intriguant cette mine où nous avons
atterri n'aurait jamais dû être autorisé
dans le rapport d'instruction remis au
préfet l'office national des forêts
avait donné un avis défavorable au
projet comme le montre ce document il
faut l'accord du propriétaire
selo neiges pour le compte de l'état
donc il faut l'accord de l'onu c'est la
première condition pour que le dossier
puisse être présenté en commission des
mines des gestionnaires avis défavorable
de la nef s'est finie normalement avis
défavorable relève
et pourtant ces patients france alors
que pour l'eau nf la mine représente un
danger pour l'eau potable
le préfet autorise le projet plusieurs
associations attac la décision en
justice deux ans plus tard
le tribunal administratif déclare la
mine illégale mais il est trop tard
quand le jugement est tombé l'activité
était fini l'activité d'extraction mais
l'opérateur est parti avec son bain
parce que pendant le temps qu'il a
exploité et la veine autorisation de la
préfecture pour l'unité dans les clous
c'est le préfet qui était pas dans
l'excès c'est la france qui était dans
les clous
ces 100 hectares de forêt primaire
n'aurait jamais dû être détruits
pourquoi la préfecture
n'at-elle pas tenu compte de l'avis de
l'eau nf
je retourne à cayenne pour rencontrer le
préfet qui a donné l'autorisation
d'exploiter cette mine en 2018
il n'est plus en poste le nouveau préfet
a accepté de me rencontrer
bonjour messieurs préfet merci nous
recevoir entre et le haut fonctionnaire
reconnaît que l'état fait une erreur
nous sommes dans un état de droit donc
c'est assez réconfortant d'être dans un
état de droit c'est que l'état prend une
décision
une personne ayant intérêt à agir
saisi le tribunal administratif qui dieu
merci ne donne pas forcément raison à
l'état
cette jurisprudence car c'est une
jurisprudence du tribunal administratif
de cayenne et une jurisprudence
intéressantes dont nous tiendrons le
plus grand compte dans l'étude des
dossiers futur
à l'avenir le préfet promet de faire
preuve de plus de vigilance
mais pour les projets de grande ampleur
les décisions se prennent à paris loin
de la préfecture de guyane
[Musique]
en 2017 deux multinationales sont sur
les rangs pour un projet gigantesque la
montagne d'or
comme on le voit sur ces images de
synthèse il faudrait creuser une fosse
gigantesque de 120 mètres de profondeur
au milieu de 1500 hectares de forêt
primaire rasé mais face à la
mobilisation citoyenne le 29 mai 2019
l'état annonce l'arrêt du projet
le conseil de défense écologique a
décidé de constater l'incompatibilité du
projet actuel minier montagne d'or avec
les exigences de protection
environnement cette décision marque tels
l'arrêt de mort des grands projets
industriels dans la forêt guyanaise
pas si sûr
il y a quelques mois une des plus
grandes entreprises de la guyane la
compagnie minière espérances
associé au numéro un américain du monde
dépose un projet d'extension de cette
mine déjà en activité
si le projet est validé par l'état sa
superficie devrait atteindre 151
kilomètres carrés
[Musique]
manouchka pons est une militante
écologiste
elle s'est battue contre la montagne
d'or pour elle cette nouvelle demande de
permis est une provocation un an avant
on dit le projet montanes d'heure ne se
fera par l'état parce qu'ils répondent
pas aux exigences environnementales et
puis un an après on a sur la table un
nouveau projet industriel d'une
multinationale avec extraction avec du
cyanure ce qui est très important pour
les milieux et c est certain c'est
l'histoire qui est qu'ils recommencent
pas
à la tête de ce nouveau projet la
présidente de la fédération des
opérateurs miniers
carole ostorero une des femmes
d'affaires les plus puissantes de guyane
mais ce 24 septembre elle a d'autres
préoccupations
une de ces compagnies gold or est
poursuivi en justice pour pollution
environnementale
la chef d'entreprise s'entretient avec
son avocat avant l'audience à l'origine
des accusations
l'office national des forêts voici une
des photos prises sur place par ses
agents dans cette roue et dans la forêt
la mine aurait rejeté ces déchets dans
une rivière
[Musique]
les prélèvements de l'eau nf ont révélé
des taux de pollution très élevé
on est sur un niveau de pollution qui
est historique
je rappelle c'est 4800 x la norme
autorisée
on est à 18 une 1000 mg par litre de
matières en suspension dans le même dans
l'eau alors que la limite qui a été fixé
par l'arrêté préfectoral est de 35
le milieu est totalement détruits sur
plusieurs kilomètres se dire qu'il n'ya
plus une seule vie aquatique qu'une
seule
plante c'est une destruction totale du
milieu naturel
l'audience va durer cinq heures carole
ostorero conteste les analyses de l'eau
nf
le parquet requiert une peine de 80
mille euros damende dont 48 euros avec
sursis contre sa société
le jugement sera rendu le 4 décembre à
la fin de l'audience
nous tentons d'interroger la chef
d'entreprise c'est mon avocat qui répond
à vos questions il est là pour ça et
c'est avec plaisir
selon l'avocat lankais de l'eau nf n'est
pas fiable
moi je prétends et ge affirme toujours
qu'il n'y a pas eu de pollution dans le
cadre de gaulle d'or puisque
règlementairement rien n'a été fait dans
les règles
voilà donc ya pas de pollution n'y a pas
de débat sur ce sujet
cette affaire judiciaire va-t-elle
empêcher la femme d'affaires de mener à
bien son ambitieux projet de mine d'or
industriel
le préfet qui doit donner son avis
tiendra-t-il compte de cette procédure
judiciaire je lui ai posé la question
d'abord moi je ne suis pas le parquet du
procureur de la république
moi je respecte les procédures
administratives est pour l'instant au
moment où on se parle le résultat de
l'instruction de ce dossier
le résultat n'est pas définitif et le
préfet ne se montre pas plus loquaces
sur son avis mais c'est la vie que j'ai
pu donner est un avis écrit qui est
remonté à paris et ça n'est pas un avis
qui est public
vous ne savez pas ce jour vous ne savez
pas quel a été mon avis
donc je ne vous le dirais pas et c'est
un avis qui est équilibré ce n'est pas
en guyane mais à paris au ministère de
l'économie et au ministère de l'écologie
que le dossier sera tranché il faudra
encore attendre plusieurs années pour
savoir qui des intérêts économiques ou
de la forêt l'emportera
[Musique]
et